allora oggi vorrei parlare
di alcune considerazioni alcuni pensieri
che io ho sviluppato in questi anni sono
ormai dieci anni che venere.com è stata
venduta è stata ceduta xperia partita
come piccola piccolissima start up
anzi in realtà non era nemmeno una start
up era un gioco come diceva il video
precedente era un gioco che noi avevamo
iniziato io e tre colleghi
dell'università di fisica dove
studiavano perché avevamo scoperto una
cosa che si chiamava che si chiama
ancora tutt'ora internet internet
a quell'epoca lì nel 1995 non esisteva
nelle case esisteva soltanto all
università a fisica
l'infn aveva portato aveva una rete che
collegava le università con i centri di
ricerca e con i laboratori per esempio
quello del gran sasso di cui abbiamo
sentito stamattina
insomma prima scusate è quella rete noi
abbiamo incominciato a pensare come
strumento per sviluppare altro ci siamo
guardati intorno e abbiamo incominciato
a pensare che sarebbe stato fico sarebbe
stato bello sarebbe stato divertente
fare un'altra cosa e quindi ci siamo
inventati quella cosa che poi è
diventata venere.com ossia un portale di
prenotazioni per alberghi
oggi però non voglio parlarvi di questa
storia è una storia molto bella molto
intensa molto anche grande ma voglio
parlarvi un pochino di quello che è
venuto dopo cioè dopo aver venduto
l'azienda che era diventata nel
frattempo molto molto grande
io mi sono trovato in qualche modo
dall'altra parte cioè se mi son trovato
a parlare con altri imprenditori con
altri ragazzi non ancora imprenditori
con altri inventori innovatori
chiamateli come volete che
volevano in qualche modo fare percorso
aveva fatto io insieme ai miei ex soci
ormai e sviluppare qualcosa di nuovo
volevano per esempio essere finanziati
volevano dei consigli volevano delle
strategie delle idee
volevano una valutazione di quella che a
loro la loro idea e quindi diciamo
questo è stato un percorso lungo sono
dieci anni ormai che io mi trovo a
vedere start up e quindi diciamo ho
cercato anche di elaborare una serie di
idee su come valutare una start up che è
una cosa difficilissima come si fa a
capire se un'azienda o meglio quella che
ancora non è un'azienda poi potrà avere
successo negli anni successivi le cose
che possono andare storte sono infinite
come faccio io a valutare sulla base di
un'idea sulla base di un prototipo sulla
base di persone che mi trovo davanti
ecco allora io credo che sia importante
intanto capire che cos'è quella che si
chiama innovazione no sappiamo sempre
che diciamo diciamo sempre si dice
sempre che le start up sono aziende
innovative
c'è anche un registro delle aziende
innovative che sarebbero re start up
ecco io credo che questa sia una
definizione un pochino tricky cioè un
pochino misleading diciamo così cioè che
porta un pochino fuori strada
le start up sono aziende e realtà che
cercano un modello di business che
potenzialmente porti l'azienda a
crescere molto
questa crescita impetuosa che le start
up cercano perché all'inizio non c'è
niente quindi bisogna semplicemente
provare a vedere se la cosa funziona è
un qualcosa che è possibile perché si
cerca un modello che sia ripetibile
scalabile questa è una definizione
diciamo abbastanza standard di start up
questa replicabilità e scalabilità del
modello di business
la si ottiene con la tecnologia con
l'innovazione computer processi
automatizzati
tecnologie che permettono di o anche
semplicemente modelli di produzione che
possono essere replicati per esempio i
ragazzi di come si chiamano quelli che
gli architetti in realtà solo una start
up per che loro usano una tecnologia che
è l'architettura per cercare di
abilitare mondi che non parlano con
quella tecnologia in maniera innovativa
ok e poi essere scalabile perché loro
potrebbero immaginare di fare dei
laboratori in diverse città o in diversi
quartieri in maniera parallela cioè non
devono essere sempre loro a fare quella
cosa lì quindi anche quella è una start
up usano la tecnologia l'architettura
per cercare di cambiare le cose
ok questo è quello che fa una sterzata
quindi vediamo un attimo allora di
rimettere un po in fila le cose prima
cosa
l'idea l'idea è un qualcosa che compare
nella mente di una persona in genere
ho un'idea spesso ho avuto un'idea
voglio fare questo bellissimo appunto
prima la ragazza della plastica
riciclabile e biodegradabile diceva ho
avuto un'idea devo fare il salto e
andare dall'altra parte del burrone cioè
lanciarmi di provare a realizzarla
quell'idea benissimo quindi l'idea è un
qualcosa che nasce nella terza una
persona e quindi non è nulla finché non
viene immessa a terra di solito si passa
attraverso una cosa che si chiama
invenzione si fa un prototipo si fa una
tecnologia si fa un modello si fa un
brevetto un qualcosa che si possa
brevettare qualcosa che non sia
immateriale come un'idea ok diventa un
disegno su carta diventa un qualche cosa
che coinvolge anche altri non è più
soltanto un'idea che sta nella mia testa
incomincia a coinvolgere delle persone e
ottengo un prototipo per esempio
ed ecco che compare il passaggio
successivo l'invenzione di per sé sta
nel laboratorio chiamiamolo così è in un
posto chiuso e isolato dal mondo in
condizioni ideali
nel momento in cui io voglio far
diventare questa
invenzione e innovazione devo portarla
dentro un ambito più ampio in cui
immagino incomincio a lavorare a come
portare questa invenzione a terra cioè
diciamo sul mercato nella società per
farla usare alle persone
e qui sta il passaggio difficile cioè
fino a qui diciamo è quello che fanno le
start up che hanno un'idea fanno un
prototipo arrivano a diciamo costituiti
per esempio una società o comunque una
attività di gruppo d'imprese eccetera e
hanno un innovazione un'innovazione che
è un modello di business nuovo che è
basato su una tecnologia sul software su
una macchina su quello che volete
ok questo è il discorso come fa quelli
innovazione a diventare valanga cioè
appunto a diventare una cosa che
riguarda tutti ovviamente questa è la
valutazione più difficile
chiaramente dipende dalla bravura delle
persone dalle loro competenze della
capacità di lavorare insieme di elementi
son finiti sono infiniti
oggi abbiamo sentito anche chi ci ha
parlato di come valutare come trovare
competenze come fare per valorizzare le
persone che sono in azienda eccetera ma
l'altra cosa che va considerata non sono
ovviamente anche il prodotto non è
soltanto questo
ma è come poi quella innovazione viene
trasferita all'esterno e questo io ho
visto è una cosa che spesso viene un
pochino poco considerata
appunto come fa un innovazione a
diventare valanga io qui ho pensato un
paio di esempi ce ne sono stati in
realtà ne abbiamo visti anche quest
ultimo video alcuni e se ne possono fare
tantissimi per esempio questa è la prima
automobile si chiamava benz patent
motorwagen ok 1886 inventata dal signor
band un attrezzo inutilizzabile di fatto
pericolosissimo come vedete non ha
niente davanti non ha nemmeno un volante
perché era una specie di leva per per
girare è una specie di carrozza ok non
ha nemmeno un serbatoio nella sua prima
versione dovevano rincorrerla con un
recipiente pieno di benzina per riempire
il carburatore mano a mano che questa
macchina questo oggetto macchina questo
attrezzo andava avanti ok le persone
la vedono passare tutti terrorizzati
alcuni meravigliati ma sostanzialmente
c'è che è sta roba
una cosa assurda assolutamente inutile
perché perché esisteva al cavallo
resisteva la carrozza resisteva al treno
esistevano altri mezzi di trasporto
non c'era nessuna necessità di questa
tecnologia che ci facciamo questa
tecnologia puzza scomoda e pericolosa se
questo prende una buca cascata in avanti
mi ammazzate a una serie di svantaggi
terrificanti
tant'è vero che questa cosa non funziona
non funziona per niente non si vende non
lavora nessuno non gli interessa nessuno
ma poi arriva il signor burns va in
depressione ma per fortuna una moglie
molto molto molto brava molto
intelligente che capisce qual è il
problema
e qual è la soluzione
quale soluzione risolve questa questo
oggetto
questo è un cavallo che non si stanca
mai bisognava esprimere questo oggetto
in un linguaggio che fosse comprensibile
a quell'epoca lì a quelle epocali
esistevano i cavalli ma cavalli si
stancavano perché bisognava fare dei
cambi
no nelle stazioni di posta poi c'erano
tutta una serie di problemi e cioè che
ovviamente se pioveva ci si bagnava
certo c'erano le carrozze ma la carrozza
erano scomodi c'erano tutta una serie di
problemi molto complicati allora cosa fa
la signora band organizza un viaggio e
va a trovare la sua famiglia che si
trova a 90 chilometri di distanza e
torna in giornata cioè fa qualcosa che
per quell'epoca era impossibile da fare
con la tecnologia esistente in questo
modo comunicando poi questa sua cosa
questa cosa che ha fatto effettivamente
spiega a che cosa serve sta roba qua c'è
racconta e dice che cos'è questa novità
se voi andate a guardare in realtà
questo meccanismo è comune a tutte le
invenzioni a tutto meglio scusate le
innovazioni che diventano disrupted cioè
che diventano una vanga ogni volta
bisogna in qualche modo spiegare la
novità in termini di linguaggio
precedente in termini di qualcosa che le
persone capiscono
bisogna costruire una metafora cioè un
immagine come diceva gian paolo orsi
prima un'immagine che spieghi quello che
fa l'innovazione
se io non trovo un modo di spiegare a
chi già usa altra tecnologia
la nuova immagine e la nuova tecnologia
che cosa serve e perché è meglio io non
riuscirò a far svoltare diciamo a far
diventare l'innovazione a far diventare
la mia start up la mia modello di
business eccetera qualcosa che diventa
globale
questo è un altro piccolo esempio il
keynote storico scusate steve jobs nel
2011 presentò il no scusate non 2011
euro al 2009 presentò il primo iphone
ok e qui cosa fece lui per spiegare
perché aveva molto senso utilizzare un
touchscreen cosa che già esisteva a
quell'epoca e lasciar perdere le
tastiere che esistevano su tutti gli
smartphone che anche quelli esistevano
era possibile leggere le mail sul
telefonino non è una cosa nuova era
possibile anche utilizzare una tastiera
estesa su telefoni erano tutte cose già
possibili lui dice la grande innovazione
di questo iphone e il fatto che lo
possiamo utilizzare con il sistema di
puntamento più avanzato che esiste qual
è il dito questo è il passaggio chiave
per cui questo questo oggetto diventa
rivoluzionarie infatti qui parla di
rivoluzione user interfaces riferendosi
al mouse
all all al podcast e scusate all ipod e
poi all'iphone
andiamo rapidamente avanti in qualche
modo la startup deve divulgare la
propria tecnologia così come piero
angela divulga la scienza ok il lavoro
di piero angela e un lavoro che in
realtà poi serve alla scienza tante
tante ragazzi tanti che poi vengono a
studiare fisica magari lo fanno anche
perché hanno visto piero angela quindi
la novazione va raccontata con un
linguaggio che già esiste questa è la
grande la grande cose siamo la cosa che
io ho capito in questi anni di lavoro
con le start up
questi sono altri esempi in modo come
gli indiani americani chiamavano il
treno il cavallo di ferro oppure come
chiamavano il whisky l'acqua di fuoco
ecco bisogna trovare un linguaggio che
sia così
bisogna trovare la metafora che faccia
vedere il significato della novità che
faccia capire che cos'è la mia
innovazione e allora dobbiamo aggiungere
la definizione di start up
questa cosa e cioè start up di successo
divulgano l'innovazione tramite una
narrazione che in qualche modo la
nasconde perché non parliamo
dell'innovazione ma parliamo dell'uso
che se ne fa
ma ne rende immediatamente comprensibili
gli effetti e questo diventa anche un
modo per in realtà tutte le aziende di
un modello che a detta può essere
applicato a tutte le aziende anche
quelle più grandi per quello che poi nel
titolo messo questo come esito finale
dicendovi questa
riflessione in qualche modo finale e
cioè l'imprenditore in fondo è un
visionario e un qualcuno che vede al di
là che vede qualcosa che ancora non c'è
ok in qualche modo a me piace pensarlo
come un appassionato di innovazione come
una persona che vede molto al di là del
tempo così come abbiamo visto nel video
di prima no degli esempi charles babbage
che immagina un uso diverso della
macchina per fare del del telaio
automatico così come quello che
inventate l'aiuto matico vede un uso
diverso del carillon per fare un telaio
automatizzato quindi un appassionato di
innovazione e cerca quello che
effettivamente cerca quelle invenzioni
che possono effettivamente modificare e
cambiare la vita delle persone e deve
trovare il modo di comunicare questa sua
visione questa innovazione che ha
scoperto che ha pensato di attuare
altrimenti la rivoluzione che lui è
immaginato non si realizzerà questo è
quello che volevo portarvi oggi come
contributo grazie a tutti e buonasera